a powerful story about perseverance and
courage from a survivor of the Boston
Marathon bombing ten years ago Rebecca
Gregory and her five-year-old son Noah
attended the race as Spectators when a
bomb exploded just feet away from them
Gregory's body shielded Noah but she was
seriously injured eventually losing her
left leg for our series note the self
Gregory shares a letter with her younger
self about what happened that day her
determination and her mission to help
others
laughs
dear ten-year-old Rebecca right now you
were sitting on the school sidewalk with
a suitcase beside you waiting for your
dad to pick you up you feel embarrassed
and abandoned because he didn't show up
again
his abuse is not your fault
and I wish I could take away your pain
but I can't
[Music]
what you will learn many years from now
is that the hurt you feel will fade away
but the impact from it will become your
legacy
for now call your mom and she'll be
there
she always will be and for many years to
come
while you wait why not make your sisters
laugh like you're good at you're going
to need that humor later on when you
don't have a leg to stand on
I can't promise it's going to be easy
Rebecca
some challenges you will bring on
yourself
and others you will have zero control
over
before you know it you will be a mom at
just 20 years old
you will have no clue what you're doing
but your son Noah will give you a
purpose that you've never experienced
before
you will grow up together and he will
teach you make you a better person and
save you time and time again
[Music]
by your mid-20s you will feel stability
and happiness you and Noah will have a
beautiful home in Texas your career will
be thriving and for your 26th birthday
you will travel to Boston to attend the
marathon with a guy you've been seeing
who you will later marry
that day in 2013 will change the
trajectory of your entire life
there's been a terrorist attack in
Boston two bombs were placed in the
crowds the two explosions killed at
least three people at least 144 were
wounded when Noah is sitting down on
your feet a bomb will explode less than
three feet behind you
and your body will shield him from the
shrapnel
it's a lot to take in I know
[Music]
and as you navigate through the ups and
downs of your recovery it will be a lot
you'll undergo 76 operations you'll lose
your left leg below the knee you'll lose
your grandparents your fairy tale
marriage after tragedy any sense of
normalcy but what you will gain will be
indescribable
you will learn to adapt to a new normal
and do things you never knew you were
capable of
like running in the Boston Marathon on a
prosthetic leg this was the hardest
thing that I think I've ever had to do
and went across the Finish Line I just I
took my life back today
and confronting the remaining bomber in
federal court
you will look him in the eyes and tell
him that you are not his victim
and you will promise that you will use
your time left to make the world a
better place
when you least expect it you will
reconnect with and marry your college
sweetheart and he will be your best
friend
together you will fulfill the promise
you made in court by starting a charity
called Rebecca's angels where you will
fund trauma therapy for nearly 500
families in the first five years
you will have a miracle baby named Riley
a little girl that no one thought you'd
have with all your injuries from Boston
[Music]
despite her early entrance into the
world and her stint in the NICU she will
be perfect she is a fighter just like
her mom
every day when you wake up you will
reach for a prosthetic leg or a
wheelchair but you will remain so
thankful
you will have a deeper understanding
that life is fleeting and you will soak
up every single moment grateful to be
alive with the family you fought hard
for
your children are so very loved Rebecca
Riley is the daddiest girl that you
always wanted to be
you love being their mom
[Music]
[Applause]
the wisdom that you have gained you will
travel the world sharing your story and
write that book you were dreaming about
you'll realize every Twist and Turn is
necessary to get you to where you are
and sometimes the most broken parts of
life lead us to the most beautiful
chapters now do you see why I can't
scoop you off that sidewalk
all that pain is part of the recipe for
the good stuff
and as long as you wake up with that
beat in your chest and air in your lungs
you have so much purpose
foreign
so do your best to keep surviving right
now so that you can fully live later
soon every broken piece of you will heal
and you will take your life back
because you are a Survivor and no one
can ever take that away from you
love always your older wiser yourself
Rebecca was hoping to run the marathon
this year but after her most recent
surgery that wasn't possible but guess
what her husband Chris stepped up and is
running in her place today I want to
wish Chris good luck in the race today
and say hi of course to Noah and Riley
Noah being a Survivor himself beautiful
family Noah you got so tall I know
that's what I thought but it's been 10
years but I'll bet he's a great big
brother and Chris her husband such a
beautiful story yeah I like what she
said most broken part of life sometimes
brings us to the most beautiful places
paraphrasing there as long as you
haven't beaten your chest and air in
your lungs I always wonder about that
it's terrible to have to suffer to get
to that point of Nirvana and
Enlightenment but we all have to
sometimes live through things like that
to get to that point yep beautiful